je peux plus vous donnez rendez vous on
est complet et que l'on fermera au 30
juin alors combien parce que plus de
doctorats faire un film c'est ça la
france
[Musique]
nous avons passé différentes va nous
demander dans les magazines spécialisés
mais nous n'avons eu aucun aucun contact
nous avions trouvé trois médecins
étrangers hors union européenne qui
était d'accord pour venir sur montluçon
mais il y à la validation de leur
diplôme qui demande plusieurs mois la
dernière médecin qui reste fait 21
heures par semaine donc travail
habitants et son contrat se termine fin
fin juin donc nous n'avons pas d'autre
solution que de fermer maman 89 ans elle
a des troubles cognitifs très important
et on n'a plus de médecin traitant
on n'a aucune solution puisque j'ai
appelé de nombreux médecins sur
l'admiration du son et par an est en
mesure de prendre un nouveau patient je
sais pas me rend aux urgences mais on
est outré on écouterait dans une ville
comme on le sens où on se promène de
cabinet en cabinet on nous dit je ne
prends pas de nouveaux clients
on ne connaît pas toutes les raisons
bien sûr mais je comprends pas
[Musique]